>>female speaker: Just a quick introduction,
because many of you already know Van Jones
very well.
So this is really short.
Yale Law school graduate, former green jobs
adviser to the Obama White House.
Co-founder of numerous progressive nonprofit
organizations.
A husband and a father.
And he is here today to talk about Rebuild
the Dream, that platform as outlined in his
new book.
Here's the advertisement.
[Laughter]
>>female speaker: Anyway please welcome, Van
Jones Johnson.
[Applause]
>>Van Jones: See you're kind a lopsided on
the side so I might favor this side a little
bit more, no offense.
Well first of all I'm glad to be here.
This is the first talk I've given on the book.
I've been on TV, but it's been really short.
So I'm gonna get a chance to talk for a little
bit longer.
I also want to acknowledge that my colleagues
are here.
The name of the book is Rebuild the Dream.
But also the name of the organization is Rebuild
the Dream.
And I want to just give a round of applause
to Natalie Foster, Jim Pugh, and Tyler who's
taking my picture right now.
[Applause]
>>Van Jones: So you guys just, just turn around.
So, since it was such a short introduction
which I kind of appreciate.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: I was, that was good.
For people who may have missed some episodes
in the Van Jones sitcom.
I used to be a grass-roots outsider.
In the Bay Area.
And I used to work with low income kids.
Kids of color.
My job was trying to get kids out of jail
and into jobs.
And discovered that there was a big wave of
jobs coming in the green sector, in the clean
tech sector.
And so I came up with this great slogan, 'Green
Jobs Not Jails'.
You see.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: Which I thought was genius.
Van Jones: And it wound up turning my life
completely upside down because it turns out
at that point in time if you went into Oakland
and you talked about green jobs they would
say, "I'm for that you mean jobs with money?"
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: I'm like, no.
And so big education on that side.
And then on the clean tech side, they were
for the green.
They didn't understand the connection between
the jails thing.
So it wound up being a really tough thing
to sort through but we were able to achieve
something in Oakland.
And it was called the Green jobs Corps.
When we got the Oakland city Council in 2007
to pass I guess a piece of local legislation
that led a lot of young kids in the community
get trained to put up solar panels.
And to weatherize homes.
And so it was a huge light bulb moment for
a lot of people.
And there was a woman named Nancy Pelosi who
at the time when we first started was just
getting underway as Speaker of the House.
And she took me and my friends to Washington
DC and we got this guy named George W. Bush,
who you may have heard of, to sign into law
something called the Green Jobs Act to make
that possible all across country.
And I wrote a book and it came out and it
was called 'The Green Collar Economy', also
on sale.
[Laughter]
And a guy named Barack Obama read it.
And I wound up going to the White House to
help implement some of these programs.
It was the best six months of my life.
Followed by the worst two weeks of my life.
So, you can Google and find out about that
if you don't know about it.
But I then took some time off.
I taught at Princeton for a year.
And I tried to kind of make sense of what
I had observed.
And having been a grass-roots outsider and
then having become a White House insider and
then being an outsider again I kind of had
this 360° view of some of the ways that people
who have ideas and values like mine were just
missing each other.
And missing opportunities to make a bigger
difference and a better impact.
And so I wanted to write both a book to express
ideas but also to try and do something about
it.
For me, and I again.
Before I went to work for the Administration
I could sort of kind of have a more nonpartisan
pose.
I kind of have to confess I'm on the left.
This may shock some of you.
[Laughter]
And from that perspective I remember 2008.
And I remember November 2008.
And I remember how that felt.
My father had just passed away a few months
before.
He, growing up poor in the segregated South
he had to fight just to be able to get any
job.
He was finally able to get a job in a school
system after lawsuits.
And then he was able to become a principal
of a small junior high school.
And he had grown up in poverty.
He got himself out of poverty.
He put himself through college.
He put his little brother through college.
He put his cousins through college.
He put me through college.
He put my sister through college.
He's kind of an original bootstrapper.
And then he spent the rest of his life trying
to get other kids out of poverty.
And his view at the end of his life was that
kids trying to get out of poverty and into
the middle class have to climb that ladder
themselves.
You couldn't give them anything that would
stop a child from being poor.
You can give them money.
But if they're poor in their heart, or poor
in their mind, or poor in their spirit.
It'll stop them from being broke but they'll
be broke again.
To get out of poverty, you got a climb that
ladder yourself.
I saw that myself in Oakland.
But he also had a view, which is my view which
is that even though that child has a responsibility
to climb that ladder, him or herself.
Grown folks have a responsibility to.
Society has a responsibility to.
To make sure that each child has a ladder
to climb.
And that's my basic view.
And that's a view in this book that yes I'm
all for individual responsibility.
I'm a dad now.
I'm a lot more for it now than I was when
I was younger.
Anybody here got any children?
Okay so chores have a totally different meaning
when you're a parent.
It's good for you.
But when I was a kid I hated it.
My only point is simply this.
I think that the ladder's fallen over.
The ladder's falling over.
And if we're to be able to be a middle-class
country.
If the next generation of people like my dad
are gonna be able to get out of poverty and
into the middle class.
And frankly if people who are in the middle
class right now are going to be saved from
falling over into poverty we're gonna have
to do a lot of things differently.
And one of the things that were going to have
to do is to take a real assessment of what
happened to that movement for hope and change.
What happened?
November 2008 people were crying in the streets.
Hugging.
Strangers in New York, I mean that's weird.
It wasn't just a partisan thing.
It wasn't just Democrats and like that.
There were, Republicans, people on all political,
sides of the political spectrum and divide
felt moved.
They thought something important had happened
or shifted in the country.
And it seemed like something was possible
there.
And yet within a year not only were we back
to the same kind of fighting, it felt worse.
And I think that a lot of people went from
hope to heartbreak pretty fast.
And I think a lot of us have been just kind
of confused since then.
I think a lot of us looking at this election
coming forward have some confusion.
I call it the post-hope Democrats.
The post-hope Independents.
Probably like this President, probably not
as in love with him as people were in 2008.
Probably like a lot of what the folks in the
Occupy Movement were saying back in the fall
but don't want to go get pepper sprayed.
[Laughter]
So what are we supposed to do?
And the book is really aimed towards the post
hope Democrats and Progressives and Independents
who are trying to figure out how we make sense
of what just happened and how we go forward.
My big insight that I try to share in the
book is I think the White House had the wrong
view of the grassroots.
I think they have the wrong theory of the
grassroots.
I think the grassroots have the wrong theory
of the Presidency.
And those two fundamental pieces of misunderstanding
created I think a lot of missed opportunities.
So on the one hand, I think that there was
a tendency not for everybody at the national
level but there certainly was a tendency for
some of the DC Democrats to think about the
grassroots progressive movements almost sort
of like something that can be pulled out of
the refrigerator, microwaved up and encouraged
to take action.
But then put back the refrigerator without
a real sense that these are kind of living
movements often.
And that the movements themselves really predated
Obama's run.
In fact I make the claim in the book that
the movement for hope and change did not start
with Barack Obama.
That Barack Obama was not the author or the
creator of the movement for hope and change.
And that in fact you can see the precursors
all the way back in 2003 with the rise of
the concern about the war in Iraq.
And then you begin to see this sort of multiracial,
people power, technologically enabled movement
starting to form that had higher hopes for
the country and wanted to change.
All of that back in 2003.
And you had groups like MoveOn.org that were
tapping into that.
There was no one leader.
There was no superstar celebrity savior that
was going to fix everything.
In fact, that was the beauty of it.
It was completely desegregated.
And yet the New York Times called it the world's
second superpower, that movement, those millions
of people that were marching against the war.
We've almost forgotten that history but that
was really the start of something important.
That poured right over into 2004 with Howard
Dean.
2005 we had Katrina which broke people's hearts
across the country.
By 2006 this movement was strong enough that
we elected Pelosi to be the Speaker of the
House.
Now mind you, 2004 Carl Rose said the Republicans
are gonna run the house and run the Congress
for 20 or 30 years.
This movement held them to 24 months.
By the time you get from 2004 to 2006 there's
been a complete flip over.
All of this was before Obama runs.
Mainstream concern about the war, before Obama
ran.
Al Gore came out.
Mainstream concerns about climate and energy
before Obama ran.
So there was a big movement happening in the
country.
And that movement luckily met this man who
needed a movement and the movement frankly
needed someone to articulate the concerns
that were beginning to rise up in the people.
And luckily somebody like Obama came along
because he took this movement to a place and
a level that nobody I know was even thinking
was possible.
And he made history.
And when the man in the movement met, he just
created this global supernova.
But I think sometimes we forget as inspiring
as Obama was at that time and often is now,
we the people inspired him first.
That's the most important thing I can say.
It was people inspired him first.
He said he had no plans to run for President
in 2004, 2005.
And yet something was evoked in him.
He said, this is the time.
Which means if there is a hope gap in America.
You can't just point at Obama.
You can't just blog about Obama.
Yeah we have this whole phenomenon now where
people it's like, I call it, 'if only the
President would read my blog'.
[Laughter]
'All would be well', right?
You know it's this is kind of phenomenon for
at least the past two or three years most
Progressives have been in this whole kind
of the debate with Obama in their brain forgetting
that we were doing stuff before Obama was
around.
In fact we were doing a lot of great stuff.
In fact it was because we were so active and
so passionate that we created the space for
someone like him to run and to win.
So on the one hand I think that there might
have been a failure to understand the grass
roots by some of the folks in Washington DC.
But I think also a failure for us to understand
ourselves.
And that became the strange projection with
regard to Obama.
We began to almost expect him to be a social
movement leader and not head of state.
And I think that's a very fundamental misreading
of American history.
Think about the most liberal President ever
right?
Not Nixon.
[Laughter]
Though he did pass a lot of cool stuff that
I'm gonna talk about.
But LBJ right?
I think we all have to agree that LBJ is probably
the most liberal President.
The war on poverty.
Not on the war fine.
But the war on poverty, the other war.
Civil rights stuff passed, he signed like
two big civil rights bills.
Probably the high point of American liberalism.
Did LBJ lead the civil rights movement?
You guys must've taken some history classes
at some point.
I know you're at Google.
[Laughter]
No, not at all.
In fact there was a vigorous civil rights
movements in the streets, grassroots people.
And there was a head of state, LBJ.
LBJ was willing to listen to and respond favorably
to the movement.
But there had to be a mover to do the moving.
And I think what happened to some of us was
Obama kind of looks like a social movement
leader.
I mean people think he's cute.
[Laughter]
Talks good.
You know.
And I think there was this thing well this
is MLK.
And he's President, right?
[Laughter]
How cool is that?
And so then you kind of sit and you kinda
wait for him to do what a social movement
leader would do.
Which is to go and challenge the consensus
and disrupt everything and stick up for the
little.
But that's not what any US President has done.
LBJ didn't lead the civil rights movement,
the people had to do that.
FDR didn't lead the labor strikes that led
to the new deal we the people did that.
Lincoln wasn't even an abolitionist that was
Frederick Douglass and John Brown and a bunch
of other people.
Nixon, you thought I was just making a funny.
But Nixon famously didn't lead the environmental
movement but he signed into law the EPA, Clean
Air Act, Clean Water Act right?
So you can have an arguably crappy President
but if you have a strong enough movement,
the environmental movement you can actually
get a lot of good things done.
So really we thought we had all we needed
when we got to Washington DC.
We had the House with Nancy Pelosi.
Best speaker ever.
We had 60 votes in the Senate and we had Barack
Obama as President we thought we had always
needed.
It turns out that's one third.
That's a big take away.
That's only a third of what you need.
You also have to have popular movements, the
Tea Party was out there as a popular movement.
They had a big impact even though they didn't
have governmental control.
And you have to have big media coordination.
Fox and the right wing bloggers played a huge
role in impacting policy even though they
had none of those levers of power.
I would argue as a Progressive that under
Bush we had the right movement for peace but
the wrong President.
And as a Progressive I would say under Obama
we had the right President but the wrong movement,
the Tea Party.
So my hope is that going forward we can both
have the right President and the right movement.
That's what I want to do, that's what the
book is about.
Can you have the right President who's willing
to be moved by the people.
But can you also have a movement willing to
do the moving.
And I think that it's possible.
And I'll tell you why I think it's possible.
I think there's a level of economic pain in
the country.
That it is historic.
You guys probably have people in your families,
cousins who you went to school with.
They are not living the lives expected to
live.
We have people who if you think about a lot
of the young people who are graduating now
off a cliff into the worst economy since the
Great Depression.
With massive debt and no jobs.
That is a relatively new, and I mean people
who went to good schools, who are struggling.
That is a relatively new development in our
country.
You think about the young veterans who are
coming home to very little hope.
Many of them with a lot of psychological and
physical scars.
When they were overseas they got a chance
to get a lot of support.
They did some nation building over there.
You know Halliburton took too big of a cut
of it from my point of view but there they
are in another country.
We dump them off at the hometown airport now
with very little support.
And they go from a military battleground with
a lot of support to an economic battleground
with very little support and the suicides
are starting to be bigger than the casualties
of war.
Now my dad's generation already went through
that.
I think we should eliminate the term homeless
veteran from the English language.
That just shouldn't be happening.
But it is happening.
You look at the homeowners.
I mean, we got a quarter of American homes
are underwater right now in terms of financially.
11 million homes people are spending more
money on the home then the home is worth because
the home got evaluated during that fantasy
bubble period.
And so you have people.
Think about this, this is the American dream
upside down and inside out.
It used to be if you were a poor person like
my dad.
How do you get out of poverty?
And into the middle class.
You go to college, you buy a home, you're
safe.
That used to be the pathway out of poverty
into the middle class.
Not anymore.
Now that can be the trap door from the middle
class into poverty.
Because you graduate with all this debt but
you don't have a job.
And the house you got may not be worth what
the bank told you it was worth.
And so you got to make a choice do you walk
away?
Do you keep bleeding yourself dry?
These are the kind of problems that are new
for the country.
But when you have problems that big then big
solutions make sense.
And what I'm hoping to do with this rebuild
the dream idea is to begin to talk about solutions
at the scale of the problem.
There's only a couple of ways you get to have
a middle class in your country.
And it's the middle class right now that's
coming under fire.
It used to be if you do economic justice work,
you're just trying to get poor people into
poverty.
Now you got it try to get poor people out
of poverty and the middle class.
Now you got it try to keep the middle class
from falling over into poverty, that's a totally
different fight.
And it's not a fight for which we are prepared
as a country.
We haven't thought this all the way through.
But you can begin to propose solutions at
the scale of the problem if you recognize
there's only a couple ways you're gonna have
a middle class in your country.
You're either going to have high skilled manufacturing
jobs or you're going to have a big knowledge
economy.
Right?
Well, we've already given away a lot of our
manufacturing jobs.
So the only real option for people in a certain
age group, 'cause you can't go get a decent
job at the factor anymore is to try to go
to college.
And try to become, get a job here with you
guys.
That would be a great outcome.
When I was growing, I was born in '68 for
us it was you know is your kid gonna go to
law school.
That was like the big deal.
You guys, you probably eat lawyers for lunch
you're like, "What, lawyers?"
[Laughter]
Like it's not, not that big a deal.
Come and work at Google that's the big deal.
But how do you get here?
Somewhere along the way if it didn't happen
at your house, somebody had to have some program,
some computer summer camping thing, something
had to happen where people got a chance to
get connected to these jobs of the future.
The problem is we're the only country in the
world for this next generation that's both
sending away the manufacturing jobs and making
it harder for people to get educated and go
to college because of the incredible high
cost of college and the big debt you gotta
take on.
That's not just bad for kids.
It's bad for the country.
How do you maintain a middle class country
when you have a whole generation you're just
gonna throw overboard into the global marketplace
with very little help?
I don't know how America gets to compete in
the world that way.
So it's not just "Oh you know why should I
care about somebody else's kid.
When I went to college I paid off my own debt.
I had several hundred dollars in debt."
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: "I paid it off myself."
I mean you hear this you know.
And then it's kinda like this failure to understand
that were talking about $25,000 or $50,000
in debt just for a BS or BA.
It costs more money now to go to UC Berkeley
than to go to Harvard.
Why is that?
It's because we used to think that educating
a generation was good for the country it's
good for all of us.
And now we think well maybe it's good for
you, you and your kids good luck.
It's a fast glide path down to a third rate
status for a country if you do that.
So we think it's an opportunity to try to
become a nation of neighbors again.
That American dream which is very easy to
make fun of if you already got it.
If you're kinda on the cosmopolitan coast
of the country or some of those like blue
dot college towns it's very easy to pooh-pooh.
"That's just consumerism.
Commercialism."
Maybe.
That's not all it is.
That's not the best part of it.
You know first thing Dr. King said about his
dream, he said "I have a dream.
It's a dream deeply rooted in the American
dream."
He wasn't talking about commercialism.
He wasn't talking about consumerism.
He was talking about living in a country where
everybody counts.
Where everybody's dreams matter.
You shouldn't have to be born rich or of parents
with a famous last name to be able to work
hard and get somewhere.
To be able to work hard and get somewhere
and give your kid something better than what
you got.
People have come here from all around the
world, all around the world.
Just to try to get a little piece of that
promise.
And you know my family we're African-American
we didn't choose to come here but we chose
to stay because of the beauty of that promise.
And I don't think we should just let it be
thrown overboard because some folks don't
want to pay their taxes because we decided
that we can just all go on our individual
routes.
We are still one country.
And were gonna rise or fall together.
We're gonna turn to each other or on each
other.
To each other or on each other.
And our hope is that we can find some common
ground now.
Because the pain, and will have this nonsense
for, till November.
It's just the way DC works.
But my hope is that, my hopes are pinned on
December.
I think in December we have a chance to stand
together again look in the eyes of these young
people.
They're in red states and blue states.
They're liberals, they're conservatives.
They're people of faith they're people of
no faith.
Some of them like a Game of Thrones, some
like Avatar you know you've met these people.
And they deserve a shot.
They deserve a shot.
And I would reject any idea now that says
you're a great patriot if you say "I just
believe in liberty, individual liberty, good
luck to you."
That there is no other value in America that's
worth defending than just individual economic
liberty.
For you.
I believe in liberty and justice for all.
It's a different way of looking at the country.
Yes liberty, yes economic liberty, yes markets,
yes the opportunity to excel.
But if all you have is that, you don't have
a country.
If that's all you've got, you don't have a
country.
We learned in the last century I'll say in
conclusion that if you just care about justice
and you don't care about liberty you get totalitarianism.
That's the big lesson of the last century.
"In the name of justice, were gonna obliterate
people's economic freedom, their individual
liberty in the name of justice."
And what ya got, totalitarianism.
That was the big lesson of the last century.
Justice without liberty is totalitarianism.
In this century we got to learn a different
lesson.
Keep that one and learn something more.
If all you've got is individual economic liberty
and no justice.
No concern about justice for all.
No concern about the community.
No concern about the next generation.
No concern about your neighbor.
You wind up with a different kind of tyranny.
You wind up with the kind of not excess concentration
of political power, but an excess concentration
of economic power.
And a lot of people left behind.
Good people.
Who have dreams and whose hopes matter.
So the book is an attempt to try to bring
us back together.
Throw a couple punches at some ideas I don't
like.
But also hopefully to be able to put that
ladder back up so we can keep the climb going
toward a country with liberty and justice
for all.
Thank you so much.
[Applause]
Questions?
>>male#1: Hi, it's amazing to see you speak
here.
I'm wondering if you could tell me why you
think college is so expensive today compared
to in the past.
>>Van Jones: Well it's two things.
The cost of education is not significantly
higher.
It's the price of education for the individual
young person.
There's something, something has gotten out
of alignment.
Part of it is that the private schools are
different conversation but I'm mainly concerned
about the public schools.
Schools like UC Berkeley that now cost more
than Harvard.
It used to be the case that again we thought
that it was good for society to have all these
kids educated.
And so therefore college was free.
Practically free, if you know anybody here
from New York?
Alright, so the CUNY system was free until,
into my lifetime right?
And then we decided that it didn't make a
lot of…
Since we wanted to have some economic.
What did you say Nina?
Okay sorry.
And produced Nina.
See, Nina is here from one part of your team
who came from that system.
So a lot of good people can make that claim.
But we backed away from the public commitment.
And there's really only two ways to pay for,
three ways to pay for school.
Debt, the individual family, and the taxpayer.
And as the families aren't making a ton of
more money and as the taxpayer backs away
what happens is that debt gets bigger and
bigger.
So now we've gotta take a look at this as
a country.
And I don't think either the Right or the
Left have all the answers on this.
But I will tell you something that shocking.
This month, what's the date of it Natalie.
April 20, April 25 this month there's going
to be, were gonna hit this historic marker
of shame.
$1 trillion of student debt in the US economy.
$1 trillion.
You say well, it's a rich country maybe $1
trillion dumped on this next generation is
not that much money.
Let me give you a sense of how much money
that is.
That's more than all of the credit card debt
in America combined.
Take all, wander around taking everybody's
credit card out in the whole country pile
it up.
It's a smaller pile of debt then just what
we have right now in student debt.
So that's bad.
I don't want to get too technical.
[Laughter]
That's bad.
And so we've got to, there's something wrong.
And I'm sure that there is plenty of blame
to go around.
But the thing about young people and I see
some people in here who look like you might
be young.
The thing about young people is when you have
a system like an education system that goes
haywire.
You know you think we'll get around to fixing
it in 10 years?
You know what happens in 10 years?
In 10 years those people who were 15 are 25.
People who were 10 are 20.
That's a long time.
And so we can't, from my point of view this
should be a national emergency.
When you have young people graduating off
a cliff every spring.
Graduation needs to be happy.
Remember that?
People would graduate and they would be happy?
Now they graduate, they look like you know
panic stricken because they got the debt and
no jobs.
And so one thing that we're doing.
We're getting broadcast everywhere.
So I want to make sure I mention this.
One thing that we should do is make sure we
don't make the problem worse.
And we're about to.
July 1, remember this date July 1 if Congress
does nothing which they tend to do.
The interest rate on the student loans is
gonna, the Stafford student loans is gonna
double.
From 3.4% to 6.8%.
Now think about this.
This is a big deal.
First of all what are Stafford student loans.
Those are that loans that the smart low income
kids get.
Right?
You're smart enough and supported enough to
get into college but you can't afford it.
You go get a Stafford subsidized student loan.
The banks right now are getting their money
for about free.
About free.
In the most needy promising young people in
America are gonna have to pay 6.8% to get
their money.
To go to college.
Just that delta will represent for the 8 million
of them that will be impacted $20 billion
sucked out of their pockets.
They don't have a nickel to spare, 20 billion.
That's the kind of stuff that Congress can
fix by July 1.
We're pushing them to do so.
If you care about that, rebuildthedream.com
is where we are gathering our forces to fight
back.
Thank you.
Hello
>> Raquel: Hi, you talked about the difference
between leadership in Presidential office
and the social movement.
And I guess that it's really not a coincidence
that in many administrations their social
movement is in crisis and opposition to whoever
is in power.
So, you know were lucky when, well from a
Progressive point of view you might say that
this was an opportunity here with Obama in
power and then kind of the first time since
he was in power for people to show that they
were passionate about something in the Occupy
Movement.
But it seemed to have fizzled so, first like
what's your take on how is it possible to
get those to both occur at the same time?
It seems like, they're always like it's like
a seesaw.
And why didn't it go anywhere you know or
maybe it still has a chance with the Occupy
Movement.
>>Van Jones: You know, that's a great question.
What's your name?
>>Raquel: Raquel.
>>Van Jones: Raquel great question.
This is a question that was driving me nuts
when I wrote the book.
So the book attempts to try to answer this.
She mentioned occupy Wall Street.
You notice it wasn't called the Occupy Silicon
Valley.
I'm serious, you notice that.
They said, "This is a class warfare movement.
These young people are just jealous and they
hate rich people and they should be ashamed
of themselves."
You remember this?
There's this TV station that's named after
a sneaky furry animal that –
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: You may have heard of.
You know they talk like that.
[Laughter]
So, but it wasn't true.
I mean if they were just mad at people who
had money they'd been out here after you guys.
Right?
It would have been Occupy Silicon Valley,
Occupy Google or something.
It wasn't, it was Occupy Wall Street.
Why?
Just to make sure to be clear about the values
of the people that were talking about let's
talk about what happened.
People in America aren't mad at economic winners.
People in America admire economic winners.
People in America hate economic cheaters.
The cheaters.
There is a difference.
See there's a difference.
There is a sense that you got some people
who have rigged the rules, rigged the game
for themselves.
So no matter how hard some of us work, we
can't really succeed.
And no matter how badly they perform, they
can't fail 'cause they're already too big
to fail.
And, but our dreams aren't and our neighborhoods
aren't and our schools aren't and our kids
aren't.
There's something wrong with that.
That just seems, it just makes people angry.
And so you saw finally this young generation
go out there and struggling folks but led
by young people.
And they went to the scene of the crime against
their future.
Wall Street.
They said "Listen, we didn't wreck this economy
you guys wrecked the economy.
But we don't have any jobs, and our parents
can't even get a break from you guys on their
mortgages and were getting charged up the
wazoo every time we use our ATMs and you guys
suck and we're mad."
Right?
Now this may not seem very sophisticated but
I tell you it totally had a positive impact,
not on necessarily Wall Street but on Washington
DC.
Because before they started talking the only
discussion in DC was: "Government's the problem
the deficit's the problem how much are we
gonna cut out of the programs for ordinary
people?"
Now if you're a progressive Democrat like
myself you say "Wait a minute, if the, the
deficit is the problem why are we cutting
stuff out of people's programs?"
We didn't, in case you guys missed a couple
episodes, we didn't go broke because we helped
Grandma too much.
Right?
It's like you know this is not true.
Clinton and Gore administration was over,
huge surplus and we just gave it all away
to Grandma on Medicare.
[Laughter]
Greedy old Grandma.
Wait a minute.
That's not what happened.
Bush tax cuts and Bush wars.
You know God bless him but Bush tax cuts and
Bush wars.
So if you want to fix the deficit you should
probably do something about Bush tax cuts
and Bush wars.
Why are you messing with Grandma?
Right?
But you couldn't have that conversation in
DC.
These young people went out there.
They started their protest.
And it proved that grassroots movements matter.
And it opened up a whole new conversation.
Now here's the problem.
Changing the conversation is not enough.
You got to change the conditions for people.
Frankly, changing the composition of government
is not enough.
Ask me how I know, we changed it from Republican
to Democrat and then Democrat and the conditions
haven't changed.
So just changing the conversation or just
changing the composition of government is
not enough.
You gotta be able to change the conditions.
And in order to do that, you got at some point
be able to move from anger to answers.
And that's what we were not able to get done
in the fall.
How do we go from confrontation?
How do you balance that with some inspiration
and aspiration.
Clarity about your goals.
How you take away that protest energy and
turn it into electoral power so you can change
the conditions?
That is the big question.
I wrote a book about the answers which is
freely available to each and all.
[Laughter]
Rebuild the Dream is the name of the book.
But the basic point I want to make about the,
what I think is possible going forward is
simply this.
I think if you reelect this President he gets
a chance to do, have another run at it.
But we also are different now.
The vote and hope strategy is over.
We're not gonna vote and hope.
Some of the young Occupiers say they don't
want to, they don't believe in the electoral
system at all anymore because it's so disappointed
with Obama.
They said they just don't believe in voting
at all.
And I tell them listen man, you know, if anybody
has a right to be disappointed or frustrated
with the Obama moment.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: I might qualify.
So, but I know something about elections.
You cannot get everything you want in that
voting booth.
But if you don't vote, you can lose everything
you've got in the voting booth.
You can't get everything you want out of voting,
but if you don't vote you can lose everything
you got out of not voting.
So it's messy.
So you gotta vote and do something else.
So my view is we have a shot.
Even though the occupations are over and Occupy
Wall Street itself isn't getting as much attention.
The themes they made popular are just as popular.
The concern about this economic inequality.
The concern that the people who've done well
in America don't want to do well by America
and pay their taxes without complaining about
it.
The idea that you have this generation that's
falling behind.
The idea that Wall Street got bailed out and
Main Street got left out.
That is just as salient today as it was when
people were out there in those tents.
I think it's up to us to figure out then how
we get Fannie and Freddie for instance.
Who have half of America's mortgages just
cut the principal.
Just reevaluate the houses fair.
Let America's families pay the mortgages back
fair.
You know what that would be, that would be
$90 billion back in the pockets of ordinary
people.
And 1 million jobs created, you know why.
Because if you got a house that's underwater,
you're not gonna go buy a sofa.
You're not remodeling.
You're not creating local economic activity,
all your money is being sucked out to Fannie
and Freddie and the Wall Street banks.
Stop it.
You reevaluate those houses fair.
And give American families a chance to get
back on their feet so we can start.
That's 1 million jobs and $90 billion saved.
You know what we can do that, tomorrow.
One guy named Ed DiMarco, he works for President
Obama.
He could do it [snap] tomorrow.
But we don't have a movement that's making
that demand salient yet.
So now if you take, if you don't have President
Obama there.
Maybe you have somebody else that I would
like less.
The movement you've got to have to get that
victory might have to be 10 times bigger.
So it's pretty smart to try to win in November
I try and tell the younger people.
Try to win in November politically.
So we can win December, January, February,
March, April, economically.
It is possible.
It's not the normal thing, but these are not
normal times.
>>Raquel: Thank You
>>Van Jones: OK
>>male#2: So just along those same lines in
terms of an effort to try and align the aspirations
of a movement and the willingness of federal
political leaders.
What's the role of the private sector in that
effort?
And then if you have specific ideas on what
our company can do to try and work towards
that as an organization and not just as individuals.
>>Van Jones: Sure.
Well I mean.
First of all the private sector is gonna be
the main engine in the recovery.
And it's trying to be.
The problem that we have right now is that
the best people, the best new companies, the
best new ideas right now I think have a big
problem.
I'm a Green guy, clean energy person.
I know how many great ideas there are out
there on the clean and green side of our economy.
I know how many entrepreneurs are out there,
how many products are out there.
And I also know that both political parties
McCain and Obama said when they were running
in 2008 "Climate change is real."
Both of them said that.
Both of them said that we've got to have a
cap and trade system to deal with it.
Both of them said that.
And both of them said it would create more
jobs.
And they were both right.
I mean if you don't believe me, go on YouTube
and find the clip where McCain turns to Obama
and says "Climate change is a hoax."
You'll never find it.
Find the ad where McCain says global warming
is a hoax.
Or cap and trade socialism.
Or clean energy will destroy American jobs.
Doesn't happen, why?
Because at that moment both parties had faced
reality.
And they were actually competing with each
other, who was going to have the best energy
solutions for America.
So we failed to take advantage of that bipartisan
moment.
I think frankly, the other side has a lot
of responsibility for that.
But what did that mean for us, talk about
our private sector here in the US.
It meant that the $80 billion the President
put on the table in the stimulus package for
green solutions was then swamped by what our
friends in China did.
We had a moment to put those dollars on the
table with the stimulus bill and then pass
cap and trade.
How you get the private sector unleashed on
some these problems, creating more jobs and
better technologies?
You get the public investments right?
Did that, $80 billion stimulus package for
green and clean solutions.
At that time the biggest investment in clean
energy in the history of the world.
At that point Obama was not the black President,
he was the green President.
Okay.
That's where he was in February of 2009.
Big public investment, but that's still puny,
$70 billion $80 billion still puny compared
to what the private sector could do.
So you got to get the public investment right.
And then you get the public rules right, cap
and trade.
To get the private sector to come in and play.
That was, and we were set up to do it.
And then it just became politically better
to call it socialism and say that Obama is
trying to take over the energy system and
score political points in the short term and
we dropped the ball.
So then what do you have?
You have American new energy companies and
entrepreneurs out there, standing out there
now naked with no help from the, a change
of rules.
And our good friends in China say "Phew, we
almost got outflanked by the Americans."
And they went triple down on clean energy.
And are now wiping out American solar companies
by flooding the world with cheap solar.
Short term that's great, cheap solar for me
and you.
Long term that means you lose all your American
industries.
You go from importing dirty energy from the
Middle East to importing clean energy technology
from Asia and you skip all the jobs in the
middle.
And who's responsible for that?
These people call themselves patriots.
Here's my problem with it, now listen.
You take a company like a Solyndra and everybody
uses that to just beat the crap out of the
President.
But when they don't talk about is that Solyndra
benefited from a George W. Bush loan program.
That loan program was George Bush's loan program.
$2.4 billion loan program that had a 99% success
rate except for Solyndra.
Why'd it get knocked down?
Because that $2.4 million loan program was
going up against a $30 billion grant program
in China to knock it out.
But rather than us talking about how we protect
the next round of innovation in our own country,
we're doing food fight politics in Washington
DC.
Now my view is that we're, I'm all for the
private sector.
But the private sector has to work according
to rules and the rules right now are nutty.
The rules right now don't let innovators innovate.
Especially in our energy sector and that's
got to change.
No you talk about a company like Google and
some of the things that Google can do as a
company.
You know, it's very hard I think for you guys
to understand how important you have become
to the world.
I mean you guys look like normal people, I
was expecting you know wings and.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: [Laughing] That you guys would
come gliding in.
Come out of some chrysalis.
I didn't know what to expect.
So, you know I honestly haven't thought all
the way, I was just happy to meet you guys.
I haven't thought all the way through what's
possible.
But I'll tell you where the needs are.
First of all, I don't know if we're gonna
be able to create enough jobs in the short
term to take a real bite out of the pain for
this next generation.
And I think we've got, we need your help to
be honest about this.
If the big fact on the world stage is: Asian
middle classes are gonna to get bigger which
is a good thing, especially if they can grow
green, that's a great thing.
Pull people out of poverty and do it in a
green way, that will be a huge achievement
for this new century.
But if Asian middle classes are gonna get
bigger which is a good thing you may have
Western middle classes getting smaller at
the same time while that gets sorted out.
If that's gonna be an undeniable fact, then
that gap, what we do with that gap, determines
what kind of country we are.
Now that gap will be filled out by something
that we would now call an informal set of
economies.
There are only two kinds though.
There's negative informal economies.
That's also known as drugs, gangs, stealing
stuff right?
And then there's positive informal economies.
And I think there's an opportunity here for
the tech sector to really partner with people
on this.
We could become a nation of neighbors.
And share.
This sounds crazy to you.
But there's this new movement that's happening.
It's a shareable economy.
It's this thing called shareable.net, I'm
fascinated with it.
Maybe we can get our income level up, up,
up, up, up.
Maybe some income levels might even come down
a little bit.
But what if our quality of life went up?
Because we used our social capital to help
each other.
Is there some way for us to use our social
capital to begin to help each other?
Now the thing about this is we already have
a bunch of stuff in America.
You know, were still the richest country in
the world.
Richest country in the history of the world.
Got a lot of stuff here.
But we tend to hoard it.
I want to figure out some way for us to unlock
the wealth we already have and use it better.
You guys will have much smarter answers about
that than I do, but I have some insight.
Because I'm a dad.
And I know about sharing.
'Cause I have two boys who never want to share.
Here's the cool thing about sharing and then
we'll probably be out of time.
Sharing can either be really cool or really
uncool.
If you have to share.
If you are forced to share.
Sharing sucks.
But if you get to share, sharing is great.
It's called making friends right?
So think about that.
If you, is there some way to make sharing
easy and cool.
Right?
If you're sharing, if you are forced to share
because the system screwed you that sucks
right?
"The system screwed me, now I'm on my mom's
couch and I have to share this couch with
my cousin who's also screwed.
This sucks right?"
If you're sharing because the system screwed
you, but if you're sharing because you're
saying screw the system that's cool.
See.
If you are opting out of some of the rampant
materialism and that kind of thing and you're
opting into a community of people who just
share their tools and share their cars.
And you got zipcar, you got Kiva, you got
Kickstarter.
There's something beginning to happen and
technology's supporting this idea that we
could maybe do better with the stuff that
we've got.
Instead of always trying to get more and more
of it.
That won't in America displace the whole economy.
It probably shouldn't.
But it could sure make life a lot better.
And I would love to figure out some way to
be in communication and conversation with
people here.
The stuff you guys do on a regular basis if
it could be.
If we could help people not fall so far.
Just don't let people fall so far, can we
help each other?
Can we hang onto each other?
So we don't fall so far.
When people fall real far they get mad they
get angry.
They do things that are scary.
People start to fall and somebody catches
them that's a good thing.
>>male#3: You got another time for one more
question.
>>Van Jones: Yeah, one more question.
>>Male Speaker: Thanks.
A couple weeks ago Obama was in Oklahoma and
it was about the Excel pipeline.
And I'm curious to know what your senses on
juggling environmental and economic development
issues in the country.
So looking at that and also the shell and
the fracking in Pennsylvania.
And that debate.
Thanks.
>>Van Jones: A couple things.
The problem with fracking is that it's short
term smart, long-term, mid-term unknowable
and possibly not smart and long-term stupid.
Okay?
And we don't do that well with those kind
of problems right.
Short term, it's pretty smart why?
Because it sure would be great to be able
to get methane out of the ground if it's there.
And use it to keep energy prices down.
Mid-term kinda questionable because nice to
have cheap energy bad to have kids with cancer
because the water is poisoned right?
So can, they won't tell us what's in there.
Which makes me assume it's not a sugar pop.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: Right.
If there like we're doing this fracking with
Kool-Aid right.
[Laughing]
>>Van Jones: They'd probably let us know.
But since they won't let us know it makes
me think that maybe it's not Kool-Aid.
Maybe it's something I don't want in my kid's
water.
So mid-term it's unknowable but kinda scary.
You know fracking, forcing this chemical down
and breaking up the rocks and getting more
methane and now they call it natural gas.
You know natural gas comes from chili.
[Laughing]
>>Van Jones: That's methane, that's what it
is.
So, but long-term.
You got my joke, thank you.
It's not the country.
We'll talk later.
But long-term it's kind of foolish.
Because it's still carbon based.
It's still taking dead stuff, burning it,
and putting it up into the atmosphere that
already has too much carbon.
And so, and it's doing so in a way that's
disrupting the short term markets for wind
and big solar.
So now again we're just about to make the
leap into big wind projects and big solar
products which will the price is just about
work out for that.
And then you got something that's gonna be
there for a long time that won't cook the
planet.
And then "Eh never mind you know it's like
like going from one bad drug to an even cheaper
easier to get drug."
It's just bad, it's bad.
So I'm not a big fan of that stuff.
I think it's taking us away from the right
direction.
And then the whole Keystone pipeline thing.
Has really, it just makes me sad.
Because the food fight politics in Washington
DC is increasingly pushing us to do things
that just are actually bad for the country.
People say we should have the pipeline because
it will create jobs.
That's just not true.
We will create some jobs if we do this thing.
It's about 1000 temporary jobs.
Now if you count where like every piece of
metal that's used.
If you count like you can do anything with
job numbers.
You can 1 million people worked on this you
know because like somebody was at the toll
booth when the thing drove by.
[Laughter]
>>Van Jones: That counts as a job I mean you
can count.
But if you actually look at the actual number
of jobs here you're talking about 1000, 2000
temporary jobs.
Those are important jobs for people who have
them and we want them because a lot of jobs,
whoever built this was a temporary job.
So I'm not saying the temporary jobs are bad.
But I'm just saying let's just be clear were
talking about a small handful of temporary
jobs.
And frankly if we're gonna do temporary jobs
we might as well do that building wind turbines
and other stuff.
Because if the only thing you can imagine
for your temporary jobs is to like, with a
toxic pipeline through America then I challenge
your imaginational capacities.
You probably can't work here if you think
that way.
So I think that's bad.
The permanent jobs are about 100 permanent
jobs.
But what people don't get.
They say this is gonna be good for gas prices
in America.
I mean this is gas.
This is first of all the dirtiest most toxic
worst stuff on the planet Earth.
We are now scraping the bottom of the barrel
for the last of the poly carbons.
That's what tar sands are.
The last of the poly carbons.
The most toxic worst fuel.
And then it comes all the way through America
down that pipeline across our aquifers over
our farmland to be refined in Louisiana and
shipped to China.
It's not even for the US to use it.
It's gonna be refined and sent to China.
So now I don't want the people in China using
the stuff.
But here's what I know about tar sand oil.
It's the most corrosive.
They've already had so many spills up in Canada
already.
It's the most corrosive.
Now you saw the oil spill we had down there
with the BP oil spill.
Imagine if that is American farmland.
And aquifers.
You could knock out huge--
I mean why?
For a couple of thousand temporary jobs and
frankly rather they be building wind turbines.
And for a couple hundred permanent jobs and
so China can have dirty oil process here.
That doesn't make sense.
Listen, if we were having a normal conversation
with normal people on the either side of the
political divide it wouldn't even be on the
table.
They say it's just not worth the risk.
But it's good politics.
Its good point scoring.
It's good to make your bigger point about
the President being out of touch even if it
hurts Americans.
So you know I think that people who are in
your situation.
I mean you guys.
I mean I'm sure you got jobs or something
here.
But stuff you gotta do.
But what we have seen.
And this is in closing now.
We've seen young people who don't know a lot
about politics and new people in technology
fields who don't know a lot about politics
have tremendous impact on the political system.
We have a young woman on our staff named Molly
Katchpole.
Young woman, 22 years old.
She happened to before she got on our staff
happened to find out that Bank of America
was gonna start charging her five extra bucks
a month to use her debit card.
She said, "I don't have five extra bucks a
month to give the biggest bank that we've
got".
It's not fair so she put up a petition on
change.org which went viral and Bank of America
faced with either having to deal with Molly
Katchpole and her viral petition or have billions
of dollars for its own said "Never mind.
Never mind."
Same young woman.
Verizon said they were gonna charge five extra
bucks to use her phone.
She said, "I don't have five extra bucks."
She put up a petition up on change.org.
They found out that Molly put the petition
up.
And within 48 hours they said "Never mind,
we quit.
Why should we have billions of dollars?
Leave us alone."
We'll now she's on our staff and she's helping
to run this student loan campaign.
If I were Sallie Mae, I'd just surrender now.
But she wrote from her heart about it.
And she used the tools that were available
and she made a huge difference.
And I think about somebody like Molly and
you probably, some you guys probably even
know her since you're all about the same age.
Don't underestimate what you can get done.
You know.
You are so privileged.
And I don't mean that like you know if you
guys went to college like privilege is bad
like "I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I'm privileged."
No it's like.
Most people like the word privileged is a
good thing.
You've been gifted you been blessed you have
the opportunity to think about problems in
completely different ways.
To see trends way before anybody else and
start pre-adapting.
And to help people.
And everybody who uses your product is out
there right now.
I'll tell you what they're googling if they're
googling anything.
Debt forgiveness.
Clinical depression.
Education.
Home mortgage.
Look at what people are looking up right now.
People are hurting.
I would love for us to live in a country where,
we're as good to our grandkids as our grandparents
were to us.
You look at what our grandparents went through
to give us this country.
They didn't say "Every kid for themselves",
they said "We're gonna create the best country
in the world for our kids to prosper in."
And they weren't a lot older than us when
they made those decisions.
And so now we are in that same situation.
And we have a responsibility to give our kids
as good a country as we got and I appreciate
your time and attention.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]